aujourd'hui vous me donnez une mission
père le parti conservateur du canada a
un nouveau chef depuis la nuit dernière
et un auto qui promettent d'unifier son
parti mais aussi de réaliser sa vision
d'un canada plus prospère et plus unie
alors quelles sont ses principales
promesses économiques je reçois jean
pierre aubry économiste indépendant et
ancien cadre de la banque du canada
bonjour monsieur aubry john wood d'abord
quelles sont les grandes priorités
économiques et fiscales de ce nouveau
chef conservateur
je pense que soutient système économique
qui préfère un système le gouvernement
est moins présente mais il donne
l'impression que le gouvernement est
trop gros et il a aimé à long terme
réduire sa taille de façon selon lui a
permis au système privé au secteur privé
de se développer beaucoup plus ce qui
selon lui devrait faire que par exemple
la croissance du pib au lieu d'être 1 2%
par année
est ce qu'il ya dans ces mesures
monsieur aubry des idées qui sont
peut-être plus novatrice que d'autres
aussi c'est finalement dans la plus pure
tradition conservatrice loin dans
l'ensemble c'est dans la plus pure
tradition on peut faire un gouvernement
plus petits on veut donner de la place
au secteur privé et le gouvernement ne
doit pas intervenir à tout bout de champ
dans l'économie il veut simplifier par
exemple l'impôt que ce soit beaucoup
plus facile
les taux d'imposition plus bas de sorte
que les gens ne perdent pas d'argent
versé des acomptes au gouvernement mais
plutôt investir consommer ou faire
d'autres choses donc on veut bien sûr
comme vous le disiez investir dans
l'entreprise privée en fait pour
permettre cette croissance économique ce
principe comme vous le disiez que cher
aux conservateurs dans le contexte
actuel c'est à dire d'une pandémie mais
aussi d'une récession à ce que c'est un
objectif qui reste réaliste selon vous
si on est en récession on commence là un
peu vite et ça veut dire que le
gouvernement apporte le support à
l'économie de sorte que le gouvernement
est en déficit mais monsieur où tous
l'acceptent le fait que ça va prendre un
certain temps pour revenir ce qui
appelle l'équilibré budgétaire que ça va
être assez long
de sorte que cette année y arrivera au
pouvoir contre je veux rapidement
revenir à liquider budgétaire par
contact long terme il voudrait même
faire des surplus de façon à réduire la
dette
parce que selon eux selon cette doctrine
l'homme
c'est important d'avoir de la capacité
d'emprunter plus tard si on a vraiment
des besoins et pour ce faire
mais il faut sortir du clan libéral où
on en prend de plus en plus où on a des
déficits annuellement et on entend
beaucoup dire ça effectivement on veut
sortir de cette façon qu'ont les
libéraux de gouverner vous dit pas tout
de suite l'équilibré budgétaire mais
clairement il veut un retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire
absolument il veut même possiblement
faire des surplus pour réduire la taille
que beaucoup augmenté à cause de la
pandémie et pour ça il va falloir
réduire les dépenses il ne s'en cache
pas non plus à monsieur aubry veut un
examen complet justement des dépenses
publiques
une règle même qui dirait une dépense
une économie équivalente est un auteur s
car même flou sur les endroits où on va
couper est-ce qu'on doit craindre une
période d'austérité si par exemple les
conservateurs reprenait le pouvoir c'est
difficile à des disons simplement qu'il
aille
le gouvernement va être beaucoup moins
généreux qu'avec les libéraux mais on
pourrait imaginer
un moment donné où il dit c'était
parterre de faire ces surplus là il faut
couper dans les dépenses du gouvernement
et comme vous dites il type hausse et
c'est pas nouveau ce genre de tactique
électorale alors ça serait bon qu
explique ou une chose importante c'est
qui veut absolument qu'on utilise des
experts du secteur privé ou d'autres
gouvernements qui ont réussi à réduire
leurs déficits pour arriver au
gouvernement fédéral montrer à au
fonctionnaire comment fonctionne et
comment fabriquer productivité il me
fait beaucoup penser à monsieur
d'autrefois un peu son message
économique qui l'a amené au pouvoir à
savoir que yo d'efficacité réalisés au
gouvernement on va mettre des ressources
souvent externe pour ça fonctionne faut
pas oublier que l'exemple de finir sur
une plaie des ressources externes centre
est même très mal marché effectivement
phoenix est pas très bons exemples
positifs en terminant on sait que 20
autres a voulu séduire l'électorat
québécois et dans sa plate-forme
québécois justement il dit vouloir
éliminer la tps sur l'abonnement des
plateformes numériques canadienne pour
que la concurrence justement avec
netflix soit plus équitable c'est quand
même louable comme mission non chinois
mais faut pas oublier une chose que
quand on rit de lui certains impôts pour
l'offrir les mêmes services
vu qu'on réduit en place va falloir
augmenter udo toi il faut d'abord excusé
la question c'est vraiment pourquoi on
exempterait ouzou
c'est pas un bien essentiel comme la
nourriture est pourquoi il faudrait pas
leur part parce qu'il va falloir que
d'autres fassent plus grands alors
quelques zones d'ombré bien sûr dans
cette plate forme il vient d'être élu à
la tête de son parti
il y aura sans doute beaucoup de
questions qui seront posées puis
éventuellement bien sûr dans une
campagne électorale jean pierre aubry
merci beaucoup
bonne soirée